>> WELCOME BACK TO HANNITY.
I'M JASON FILLING IN FOR SEAN IN
THIS SPECIAL "HANNITY: SOCIALISM
RISING".
AFTER THE PRESIDENT TOOK A HARD
LINE STANCE ON THURSDAY, HE
CALLED ON HANNITY AT THE
POST-SUMMIT PRESS CONFERENCE.
SEAN ASKED THE PRESIDENT A
TIMELY QUESTION ABOUT HIS SUMMIT
WITH KIM JONG-UN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> A LOT OF CONDEMNATION AT THE
TIME.
AND IT ENDED UP WORKING OUT VERY
WELL IN THE END FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
WAS THIS MOSTLY YOUR DECISION,
AND WHAT MESSAGE WOULD YOU WANT
TO SEND CHAIRMAN KIM AS HE'S
LISTENING TO THIS PRESS
CONFERENCE ABOUT THE FUTURE AND
YOUR RELATIONSHIP?
>> WELL, SEAN, I DON'T WANT TO
SAY IT WAS MY DECISION BECAUSE
WHAT PURPOSE IS THAT?
I WANT TO KEEP THE RELATIONSHIP
AND WE WILL KEEP THE
RELATIONSHIP.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS OVER THE
NEXT PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, WE GOT OUR
HOSTAGES BACK, THERE'S NO MORE
TESTING.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS
IMPORTANTLY THAT HE PROMISED ME
LAST NIGHT IS REGARDLESS, HE'S
NOT GOING TO DO TESTING OF
ROCKETS AND NUCLEAR, NOT GOING
TO DO TESTING.
I TRUST HIM AND I TAKE HIM AT
HIS WORD.
I HOPE THAT'S TRUE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, WE'LL BE
TALKING.
MIKE WILL BE SPEAKING WITH HIS
PEOPLE.
HE'S ALSO DEVELOPED A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE PEOPLE,
REALLY THE PEOPLE REPRESENTING
NORTH KOREA.
I HAVEN'T SPOKEN TO PRESIDENT
MOON, SOUTH KOREA.
BUT WE WILL.
AND WE'LL TELL THEM IT'S A
PROCESS, THAT IT'S MOVING ALONG,
BUT WE JUST FELT THAT IT WASN'T
APPROPRIATE TO SIGN AN AGREEMENT
TODAY.
WE COULD HAVE.
I JUST FELT IT WASN'T VERY
APPROPRIATE.
>> THANK YOU FOR WATCHING
TONIGHT.
THANKS TO SEAN HANNITY FOR
LETTING ME GUEST HOST TONIGHT.